[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le dernier
si on parlait sport de la saison et oui
un déjà pour ce dernier numéro nous ne
changeons pas une recette qui gagne il y
aura comme d'habitude des analyses des
débats et des tués duel d'anthologie
avec nos incroyables chroniqueur
aujourd'hui sont quatre autour de la
table et croyez moi ils sont loin d'être
en vacances présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite c'est un
chroniqueur de classe internationale le
pilier de cette édition est titulaire
pour la 45e fois qu'ils t'ont ceux ci
ont parlé sport l'indéboulonnable
capitaine ya dujarrier du top 2 vélizy
78 est avec nous pendant une heure
bonjour jan bonsoir michael quand
allez-vous très très bien 45 déjà 45e
mouchoirs vous êtes titulaire
il demande sa démission est ce que vous
réalisez non non c'est pas sinon est
bonne fille on passe à ma gauche musique
c'est un vrai privilège de le recevoir
dans cette émission après avoir débuté
chez tv soit 118 il est aujourd'hui
chroniqueur chez nos confrères de rmc je
peux vous dire qu'on a dû sortir le
chéquier est passé par plusieurs agents
pour le rapatrier dans sa chaîne de
coeur le temps de cette émission
certains parleront peut-être du
transfert du siècle
l'incroyable unique le légendaire
mustapha larbaoui l'école sportive de
trappes est avec nous bonjour michael
bonjour ça va quand gagner mais ça va
très bien vous n'êtes plus gros
transfert de l'histoire de tv 70 villes
dans le sens attendu
il y avoir envoyé un message mais c'est
bien toi qui passait juste suspendu que
j'ai fait peu de sélections avec vous
mais je suis tout de suite monté en
ligue 2 à la ligue des champions donc il
suffit pas d'en faire beaucoup il suffit
d'être efficace en finale de la coupe du
monde directement moustache or passe de
l'autre côté musique notre troisième
chroniqueur est un véritable guerrier
n'hésite pas à trancher dans le vif du
sujet quand il le faut et pourrait
donner sa vie sur un champ de bataille
qui cela avec un grand self control nous
l'avons sont nommés dans cette émission
le gladiateur à pierre chevalier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
pendant une salle et mickaël formé
bonheur salut à tous
quand allez-vous pleine forme
effectivement pas en vacances parce que
l'actualité sportive et très très riches
en ce moment donc les jours sur le pont
sur le pont avec le glaive et la peau de
bête on termine de l'autre côté musique
il est arrivé sur la pointe des pieds il
s'est imposé comme un titulaire à son
poste en attaque au milieu en défense il
est partout c'est le n golo compter de
cette émission l'essuie glace je ne vous
présente plus georges de miss de plaisir
nous bien pour notre plaisir justement
salut mika c'était bonjour à tous quand
allez-vous georges très content d'être
avec vous pour pour la dernière de 2 2
avant avant avoir les quatre ans c'est
la dernière avec le titulaire numéro un
je suis très catholique des chantages
800 kg ce virage à ces messieurs
mais c'est un vrai talent sondage
présenté à chaque fois on présentation
qui met signaler facilement de semaine
l'inflation jour et demi selon ces cinq
minutes en maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de l'engouement autour de cette
équipe de france 2018 le parcours des
bleus aura-t-il un impact plus d'impact
même que la coupe du monde 98 nous
tenterons de répondre à la question les
évoquons également les plus grands
moments qui ont marqué cette année
sportive 2017-2018 mais avant de
développer ces thèmes coup de projecteur
sur la saison de nos rugbymans yvelinois
on commence donc par du rugby et les
clubs chinois ont vécu une saison
2017-2018 contrastée entre joie suspense
frissons les supporters ne se sont pas
ennuyés cette année coup de projecteur
sur montigny le bretonneux plaisir
versailles et le sky rugby dans ce
reportage avantage de exe déjà les clubs
de rugby noix sont passés par toutes les
émotions cette saison le sky rugby fêter
sa remontée en honneur après trois ans
d'absence
pour leur retour les saint-quentinois
ont lutté jusqu'à la fin du championnat
pour s'assurer le maintien il termine
finalement la sixième place du
classement
il faut pas rajouter une seule chose il
faut que charlotte est plein de petites
choses pour que ça se passe bien
fafard être meilleur a physiquement
meilleur quelques joueurs qui viennent
un peu plus un peu plus chanceux sur sur
les blessures parce qu'on a bien chargé
cette année en blessure donc donc ça ça
arrive mais elle rejoindra peut-être
besoin de moi de malchance là dessus et
après basse et toujours progresser quand
c'est à dire que là au match aller on a
fait on a fait trois victoires et aux
mascottes on a fait 3 victoires + 1 nul
donc ces lieux dans le championnat de
promotion honneur le promu montigny le
bretonneux a également flirté avec la
zone de relégation pendant la première
partie de la saison mais ils montrent un
logiciel se remobiliser à partir de
janvier pour terminer avec un bilan de
huit victoires pour 10 défaites et une
sixième place au classement
[Musique]
du côté de la fédérale 2 plaisir promu
cette saison restera dans cette division
la saison prochaine les plaisirs ont
officiellement validé leur maintien sur
le terrain de domont début avril
la victoire est sans appel 54 à 7
ce jour là les hommes de sébastien
roncalli compte 15 points d'avancé sur
le premier relégable
arras sportivement et de par le travail
effectué par les joueurs
et tout le staff et les dirigeants voilà
je pense que c'est tout à fait mérité
c'était vraiment très important
prépare vraiment des choses on s'est
projeté sur plusieurs années donc ouais
c'était vraiment important de se
maintenir cette saison
versailles a sans doute été l'équipe qui
a procuré le plus de sensations à ses
supporters après avoir terminé 3e de
division honneur derrière sarcelles et
bagneux et joueurs de la cité royale ont
réussi à se hisser en quarts de finale
du championnat de france en venant à
bout de l'entente maisons laffitte saint
jean les poissy sur le score de 13 à 3
un parcours historique qui s'est
finalement stoppé en quart de finale du
championnat de france versailles
s'incline 11 à 0 contre l'un des favoris
chalon sur saône pas de monter pour le
club
ce qu'on retiendra de toute façon c'est
que c'est une défaite à un niveau
historique pour le club
c'était la première fois que l'équipe
senior du rcv atteignait les quarts de
finale en honneur dont vous avez marre
et que voilà cesser les joueurs ont
marqué l'équipe de l'histoire du club
avec leur staff
le championnat terminé les équipes
chinoises ont maintenant plus qu'un
objectif en tête sont renforcés pour
espérer passer un nouveau palier de la
saison prochaine la question sur ce
thème les supporters biennois
peuvent-ils être fiers des rugbymans du
département oui ou non
oui oui oui
pierre chevalier
on vous a vue sur le nom reportage et
oui mais changer d'avis sur versailles
non pas du tout changé d'avis très fier
de ce que de ce que les beaux ils ont
réussi ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est
qu'après après les seniors i à toutes et
à toutes les catégories jeunes aussi qui
sont qui sont derrière qui poussent
derrière
pour l'exemple de versailles c1 c'est
une
une stratégie de formation aussi c'est à
dire de faire en sorte que la plupart
des joueurs seniors et évoluer dans les
catégories jeunes avant de avant de
jouer en équipe première en équipe
réserve
et puis là c'est une saison c'est une
saison somme toute où on a un regret
c'est de ne pas de ne pas avoir bien
géré les premiers matchs de début de
saison pour pouvoir monter direct pour
pouvoir en gros se frayer un chemin avec
sarcelles et bagneux et malgré tout
d'avoir quand même une grosse
satisfaction d'avoir réussi à redresser
un petit peu le tout d'avoir fait un bon
milieu et fin de fin de championnat en
poule pour pouvoir se qualifier en
quarts de finale le niveau le niveau le
plus haut historique mans pour une
équipe senior en honneur à versailles on
est tombé contre les finalistes une
belle équipe de chalon qui perd en
finale et et avec tout ça on a on a une
bonne équipe et on a on a on a des
bonnes perspectives vous le vous le
disiez aussi dans le dans la préparation
du reportage en gros un renforcement qui
est en cours pour pouvoir mettre toutes
les chances de notre côté pour démarrer
fort la saison gagner tous les matches
en gros et puis et puis tenter la montée
directe c'est-à-dire terminer premiers
de poule moustapha les supporters elie
baup peut-il être fiers des rugbymans
quand on voit on voit les résultats
bah non seulement non seulement une
fille hein parce qu'après tout j'imagine
qu'ils avaient des objectifs en début
d'année des objectifs a priori sont
atteints et bien atteint puisque il
s'agissait j'imagine du maintien ce même
si on a tous envie d'être premier tout
le temps et gagné tous ses matches il ya
des objectifs de club les objectifs pour
les par rapport aux dirigeants donc ils
peuvent être fiers d'eux déjà avant
qu'on en soit fier nous on peuvent être
fiers de nos rugbymans et on peut être
fier également dû pour le sport en
général pour les yvelines parce que à
chaque fois qu'un club fait ce type de
performance ou la totalité du sport dans
les yvelines à ce type de performance on
est tous gagnants nos enfants sont
attirés par le sport de bonnes manières
auquel cas on associe aux sports
d'autres choses que le sport et
l'éducatif en particulier ouais donc
tout ça c'est positif
c'est comme cette coupe du monde qu'on a
qu'on a qu'on a tous suivi pendant
pendant des semaines on voit bien
l'engouement qui a même si les bornes
bol de football pardon grandissant et au
final on voit bien que il ya toujours un
aspect positif c'est le sport qui doit
gagner et en l'occurrence pour les
yvelines c'est le cas j'aurais juste un
mot parce qu'on voit souvent les
dirigeants et je pense aux présidents de
clubs pour l'avoir été 14 ans c'est un
vrai un vrai métier une vraie passion et
j'ai un vol pour le coup j'ai un vrai
message pour ces gens là qui dirigent
ces clubs et qui font en quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel avec tous ces
dirigeants là continuer parce que vous
fait un boulot remarquable
on parle très souvent des talents sauf
que tous les talents passe d'abord par
les clubs amateurs
donc bravo à vous et bravo à vous à vos
dirigeants et vive le rugby populaire
pourquoi pierre chevallier dans les
yvelines terre de terre de vélo terre de
football
il ya une satisfaction pour répondre à
votre question c'est que c'est que le
rugby dans l'est avec les avec les
actions des différents clubs différents
niveaux régionaux notamment ou fédéraux
pur plaisir ont réussi à rendre le rugby
populaire et on en voit
moi j'ai joué à des à des temps que les
moins de vingt ans ne peuvent pas
forcément connaître
on avait beaucoup moins de monde ouais
on avait beaucoup moins de monde pour
coup moins de monde dans les stades
hélas cette année et là je tiens un coup
de chapeau à ces chauvin pour le nôtre
l'amicale des supporters qui s'appelle
le cuve le collectif des ultras
versailles et qui a animé toute la
saison sur le délai terrain
porchefontaine à versailles et sur les
terrains extérieurs ça a mis une grosse
ambiance
il y avait du monde dans les tribunes et
ça c'est bon biens durables et vous
voulez réagir par rapport à juste dans
les points
le rugby dans les tribunes ça vient
surtout des résultats de l'équipe de
france de rugby qui brille à très haut
risque c'est qu'il ya vraiment une
culture locale il ya un vrai travail en
local on donc ça montre bien qu'il n'ya
pas simplement que l'élite qui brille
parce que les résultats l'équipe de
france sont quand même catastrophique
depuis des années au niveau du rugby
c'est très très compliqué pour pour nous
de 2,2 de str s'intéresser un tournoi
des six nations ne s'intéresse à une
coupe du monde parce que prendre des
roustes régulièrement contre les contre
les grosses nations et donc voilà il va
dire que ça veut dire être également au
rugby oui le top twin pour épuiser le
plus beau championnat
à travers le monde bien sûr mais ça veut
quand même dire que les clubs en local
font un travail qui permet de rayonner
et 2 et d'attirer les jeunes vers ce
sport qui n'est pas aujourd'hui qui n'a
pas la rayonnante qu'il mérite mais est
ce que je pourrais pas la question parce
que les isérois peuvent être fiers
climat mais bien sûr il est parti on a
faim mais ils ont alors ils se tournent
des clubs qui avait qui étaient passés à
l'accession sur des divisions
supérieures
on peut pas monter tous les ans tous les
ans tous les angles donc voilà il ya des
choses qui sont créés des de
l'expérience qui a été à emmagasiner
pendant pendant toute une saison
les fruits vont se récolter un peu plus
tard ils ont ce mais ils ont ils ont ils
ont ils ont progressé tous donc donc
voilà bien sûr qu'on peut être fier
d'avoir d'avoir obtenu ces objectifs
tout simplement
on n'est pas obligé d'être champions
tous les ans pour pour aider ses
objectifs georges gomis vous êtes
confiant pour la saison prochaine liane
le disais à l'instant ils auront
peut-être plus d'expérience sur la
saison prochaine tous ces clubs qui ont
un petit peu galéré pour se maintenir
c'est cette année c'est l'expérience on
en accueille quand on participe un
championnat championnat étant donné que
rencontrent des fois des des commandes
et on rencontre des péripéties des
blessures tout ce qui s'ensuit et les
équipes et blinoise quelqu'un puisse se
maintenir en montant va bien sûr que ça
va leur servir pour la saison prochaine
évidemment les ils vont pouvoir intégrer
des joueurs qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
peut-être que des blessés il ya eu des
blessés mais il ya des joueurs qui sont
révélés peut-être cela bon devenir des
titulaires en puissance et des jeunes
qu'ont pu jouer qui vont venir et des
effectifs là ce qui va permettre de
faire une très bonne saison l'année
prochaine ça va je profite
j'adore le rugby l'esprit bistrot qu'on
a des choses des enseignements à prendre
dans le foot parce que je ne suis pas
que foot dans le rugby j'aimerais bien
que le championnat de france par exemple
se termine comme le top 14 parce que le
suspense de cette année fabuleux en
phase finale
parce que quand le sixième fini champion
quand le premier film en tapant tous les
prix tous les plus grands ça c'était
pour le suspense et g voilà donc les
fameux play off et le championnat
finalement il ya un championnat à la fin
du championnat
football en football la magie de ce type
c'est dans l'émission sujet merci mais
georges domicile a appris la vidéo c'est
vraiment énorme ici c'est non mais le
comment le rugby s'est délocalisé avant
l'été dans le sud sud ouest
alors aujourd'hui il est il est il et il
est et d'arrivée j'ai dit oui
aujourd'hui il est dans les yvelines il
893 aider dans l'île de france est bon
de le racing champion de france comment
le stade français et c'est des gros
clubs c'est des gros clubs maintenant
bon bah c'est sûr que les yvelines terre
qui est très proche peu pour en profiter
aussi pierre chevalier dernière question
qui a réalisé la meilleure saison dans
les yvelines versailles
je vais diriger un vide allons pas par
chauvinisme à papa parc pas que par
chauvinisme les versailles pour un quart
de finale pour un objectif qui est donc
vous parliez mustapha des des objectifs
tout c'est un objectif à trois ans on
est dans les plaques il nous reste une
année pour le faire remonter en fédérale
3 quarts de finale on va passer à la
deuxième thématique messieurs on range
les ballons valent pour parler de
handball plaisir a été l'équipe à suivre
cette année dans les yvelines promu
cette année en nationale 3 les plaisirs
oies ont failli monter une deuxième
année consécutive en s'inclinant en
barrage retour sur cette folle aventure
à montage de à xavier gens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2010cette année de la consécration pour
le plaisir handball club après avoir
lutté pour la montée pendant six ans les
plaisirs aux accède enfin à la nationale
3 je pense que ça représente énormément
pour le public pour le club les anciens
du club le tout les dirigeants les
bénévoles les petits c'est vraiment une
grande famille c'est pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les 12 c'est vraiment un club qu'avec
tout ce moment là tous ensemble
après l'euphorie retour sur terre
plaisir se mesurer pour la première fois
une équipe de nationale 3 en coupe de
france début septembre après un match
serré les plaisirs oies sont finalement
éliminé par le club d'ici aux tirs au
but le score 28 à 27 une défaite
formatrice pour le groupe une équipe
réellement profil des équipes de
nationale 3 à savoir bas des joueurs
avec un petit peu tous les profils et
notamment des grands gabarits qui sont
capables d'aller jouer des duels et ces
choses qu'on trouve très peu en
prénationale donc voila c'était très
intéressant de cette équipe avec voilà
nos qualités
après quatre mois de compétition plaisir
pointe à la deuxième place du
championnat de nationale 3 à trois
longueurs du leader saint polois les ivy
notamment réalisé une série de quatre
victoires consécutives entre octobre et
novembre
l'équipe a été remaniée puisque
effectivement on a perdu quelques
joueurs le fait de rappeler ces quelques
joueurs n'ont pas changé à l'état
d'esprit du groupe
l'état d'esprit est toujours positif les
mecs s'entraîne sérieusement on
s'entraîne sérieusement et donc cette
deuxième place au championnat je pense
qu'elle est méritée
maintenant on sait que ça va être dur de
la garder ma nounou battre et continuer
sur cet état d'esprit qui est pour
l'instant est repproché avec cette bande
de potes à la neil et plaisir ne sourit
plus les plaisirs wa concèdent leur
troisième défaite en quatre matchs
contre l'entente pcn le score est sévère
33 à 24 plaisir des sens la quatrième
place les barrages s'éloigne pour
plaisir et l'équipe enregistre de
nombreux blessés
le dispositif qu'on aligne sont pas les
dispositifs pour la ligne habituellement
donc forcément on essaye de trouver des
solutions là où finalement on n'a
peut-être pas
voilà mais bon c'est juste parce qu'on
essaye de rester compétiteurs jusqu'au
bout et de se battre avec nos armes
plaisir s'accroche dans le sprint final
et enregistre deux victoires et un match
nul pour terminer deuxième et arraché
des barrages les plaisirs roi s'incline
finalement contre molsheim sur terrain
neutre 27 à 26 et voient leurs espoirs
de montée s'envoler en sait trop jeu est
arrivé au match de barrage on ya
vraiment cru et sur le terrain on ya cru
parce qu'on a vraiment dominé cette
équipe de molsheim et malheureusement
sur sur le money time
ça tombe pas en notre faveur pour sa
première année en nationale 3 plaisir a
été l'équipe surprise et sera la
formation à suivre pour la montée la
saison prochaine encore un grand bravo
aux plaisirs web pour leur parcours la
question sur ce thème les handballeurs
plaisir wa doivent-ils avoir des regrets
sur cette saison vous votez oui ou non
oui pour georges gomis oui pour mustapha
ou non pour pierre chevallier et non
pour yann jarrier un petit duel entre
moustapha et yann dujarrier alors non
parce que comme j ai juste dit avant on
peut pas monter tous les ans bien sûr
que ça joue un poil de pas grand chose
un poil de bip
mais voilà ils vont avoir appris dans
cette danse est
dans cette expérience ils vont avoir
énormément progressé il l'a les
prochaines ils vont avoir qu'une idée ça
va être de monter et ils vont réaliser
l'année prochaine et ça leur servira
dans la montée progressivement et de
pouvoir se conserver à ces niveaux parce
que quand on monte trop rapidement après
on peut aussi redescendre tout aussi
rapidement la voilà ils ont solidifié ce
qu'ils avaient pu construire
conçu à l'année d'avant et est donc
resté rester tranquillement
donc c'est positif mais bien le scénario
le scénario et le scénario est dur parce
que voilà ça se joue à un but pour
pouvoir aller chercher la prolongation
et pour pouvoir continuer à rêver à 7 à
cette montée il faut pas oublier que le
match était pas à domicile donc sa salle
en terrain neutre
tac auprès d'accor se faire avant de
troquer mes donc assez ils sont tombés
contre contre plus fort
ça s'est joué ça s'est joué à peut-être
à l'envi ça c'est à au facteur chance
même si le facteur chance j'ai toujours
tendance à dire qu'on provoque c'est pas
c'est pas ce n'est pas anodin la chance
elle elle vient aux audacieux donc
donc voilà pour moi je pense que c'est
pas une vraie défaite c'est pas une
c'est juste un acte manqué voilà un acte
manqué pour vous dire que monsieur j'ai
voté comme j'aurais pas eu la parole
j'ai vu porter la contradiction mais je
suis totalement d'accord avec lui
quand même pour dire que bien sûr qu'il
peut avoir des regrets mais on en a tous
et c'est sain c'est juste que ils en ont
parce que à chaque fois qu'une équipe r
on est dans les vestiaires avec eux on
est avec eux toute l'année et on les
voit bien chagriné par le résultat par
la déception après est ce que ce sont
des remords ozon des regrets on peut
jouer sur les mots mais bien sûr qu'ils
en ont c'est juste que c'est
consubstantiel au spa hong hanh on perd
on a des regrets
pas de remords et pour le coup chacun
doit s'interroger de savoir ce qu'il
aurait pu faire encore mieux et c'est ça
l'idée selon laquelle on peut progresser
c'est que si on n'a pas de regrets sur
un pas de remords bas après tout on se
pose plus de questions finalement c'est
faute à la chance donc évidemment que tu
as raison ils doivent pas en avoir une
mais un moment donné comme on est club
formateur
on doit expliquer qu'il a quand même
manqué des choses probablement
qu'adversaire est les meilleurs
la preuve en est le résultat sur un
championnat ça ne trompe pas sur un
championnat plutôt que sur un match mais
il faut que chacun s'interroge accès
individuellement qu'on s'interroge même
dans un sport collectif et je vais plus
loin que s'interroge également les
dirigeants
j'entends les présidents de club parce
qu'à un moment donné ça doit se remettre
en cause
mais pour le coup moi je peux vous
parler de du club de foot de train parce
que je vois des images c'est totalement
semblables ce moment est différent mais
c'est très semblable dans la façon
d'organiser les choses mais on a mis
combien de temps pour passer
d'excellence en ph de péage à rien à
chaque fois sur le podium et à chaque
fois on échoue oui c'est juste que c'est
leur faut du temps c'est trop dur temps
et donc je le regarde d'abord bravo et
pas de remords mais des regrets bien sûr
est que ça soit formateur pierre
chevalier
je pose la question par le
par le score du barrage s'il avait pris
une tôle en barrages on aurait on se
serait juste rappeler tout de suite
s'ils terminent deuxièmes de poule après
une montée superbe saison bravo l'aï
perte d'un but c'est là où ils peuvent
éventuellement se laisse manger parce
qu'il perd d'un but
je pense que mais au final au final pas
de regrets les saisons changent comme il
se faisait taper sur allier moi je enfin
quand on a un suivi est quand même leur
saison de quoi j'étais quand même très
énervé il a qui n'ont vraiment très
énervé c'est excessif c'est excessif
mais bon il ya quand même des regrets
oui les regrets ils doivent les avoir
étant donné que ils ont fait une saison
avec beaucoup de blessés et malgré tout
arrive là ils ont eu pas mal de joueurs
clés qui ont été absents il arrive même
même si son retaper avancés s'ils phase
finale ils arrivent ils arrivent pas en
forme ces joueurs là puisqu'il les cieux
il faut plusieurs semaines pour
retrouver son niveau initial et céline
on peut voir des regrets de ne pas avoir
soin d'avoir peut-être tiré sur la corde
sur les joueurs l'eau si le coach il est
aussi peut être fautif parce qu'elle est
blessée c'est aussi l'encadrement
médical qui peut être des retours trop
précipitée ou de de commandes ne pas
suivre les soins voilà le seul regret
qu'ils peuvent avoir c'est que l'année
prochaine ce n'est peut-être pas aussi
proche
voilà là on a l'occasion de saisir
quelque chose avec la main de la main de
l'an de le prendre et là bas il faut
attendre un nom et dans un an peut-être
qu'il ya des joueurs qui vont partir et
ça ne sera pas le même groupe ça sera
pas le même vécu et d'en rater le coche
bah oui mais on ne peut pas nui dessus
que ça se joue le scénario fait que ça
se joue à rien bien sûr qu'ils auraient
pu mais parce que leur objectif c'est de
rester en nationale 2 en nationale 3 ils
peuvent redescendre en prénationale
l'année prochaine nancy en nationale 2
il aurait pu y rester deux ans de plus
mais c'est pas sûr que les joueurs dans
sa division les jours un gentil
ça se trouve là ils font de bonnes 16
offrandes bonne saison bon là je pense
que c'est des gens qui se connaissent
bien qui se connaissent bien c'est une
bande de potes
bon ça c'est dur s'est dit fier voilà
c'est une c'est dur de casser ça c'est
toujours deux cas c'est ça mais quand on
a un potentiel des joueurs autant plus
des jeunes joueurs c'est à dire que les
autres les ceux qui sont au dessus
bah ils vont se dire étant donné qu'ils
ont fait une bonne saison derrière les
play-offs et dillon il ya certains
joueurs qui ont le niveau
ils vont passionner pour venir en
prendre un ou deux et peut-être et
peut-être que l'année prochaine et c'est
là que ce que dit moustafa était là va
rapidement
non c'est juste regrets il y en a
probablement il faut les corriger les
gens doivent le savoir
par contre c'est surtout la déception
déception regrets momentanée la seule
chose on passe à autre chose justement
c'est parti à pour notre coup de
projecteur l'équipe de france de
football ou fait rêver pendant cette
coupe du monde 2018 en france on ne
parle plus que de killian et mbappé
antoine griezmann et de à benjamin
pavard sur les marchés les bars et les
terrains a même si la france n'a pas
encore gagné la coupe du monde au moment
de l'enregistrement de cette émission on
peut dire que la france a réussi cette
édition 2010 8 la question sur ce thème
l'effet coupe du monde 2018 sera-t-il
plus fort que l'effet coupe du monde
1998 ou et et messieurs bien dujarrier
en ferme six duels face à georges gomis
le spécialiste football
on écoutera ensuite les réactions des
yvelinois nigeria moi je oui je pense
que ce sera plus fort qu'eux
qu'il y ait qu il ya vingt ans
maintenant pour la simple et bonne
raison c'est que réseaux sociaux qui qui
va beaucoup travailler beaucoup aidé la
communication de ce team france je me
souviens qu'on avait pu avoir cette
fameuse vidéo des jeux dans les bleus
qui était passé peu de temps après cette
victoire et qui nous avait vraiment fait
en 1998 qui nous avait fait vraiment
comprendre il la vie du groupe par la
suite là aujourd'hui
cette vie de groupe ont la vie au
quotidien et avec grâce aux grasshoppers
mention série on est déjà on est déjà
dedans on sait déjà comment ça se passe
et il y aura peut-être des choses qui
vont découvertes par la suite mais on
est déjà dans cette
dans cette optique est donc pour moi
c'est vrai que messi je crois et donc
pour moi seul contre tous non donc
voilà j'ai perdu mon fils donc on est
dans une série série aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui elle qui on
communique et nous disent c'est vrai que
moi j'étais trop jeune à cette époque et
donc ils ne l'ont pas vécu là ils sont
en train de savait qu'on était donc en
avait été champion du monde mais ils me
l'ont pas d'étude et c'est cet effet va
faire que cumuler avec la médiatisation
qu'il peut y avoir d'un championnat du
monde va faire que que ça va être plus
fort que ce que ça pouvait être 80
difficile où on voit les images en ce
moment avoue pas lésés ce bordel en
cours a énormément de talent et de tout
donner
la coupe du monde 82 petit tableau voilà
où la superbe la laonnoise à la maison
la coupe du monde donc il ya 122 du
traité chez nous donc en france et donc
là on avait tous les joueurs les joueurs
français qui jouent à l'étranger
il y avait pas de comment il n'y avait
pas un championnat aussi fort
avec un paris saint germain à ce niveau
avec un monaco est niveau quand on
regarde la plus durement duffy d'accord
quand on regarde quand on regarde la
coupe du monde
on a pratiquement l'éden hazard eden
hazard qui sont passés par le
championnat france d'un rameur rodriguez
qui sont passés par le championnat
france il ya plus de 15 jours 15 plus de
quinze joueurs de différentes équipes
qui sont passés par le championnat de
france
donc là aujourd'hui le football il y
aurait moins besoin de c'est à dire que
le pg est tellement attractif il ya la
ligue des champions que les jeunes n'ont
pas besoin de de la coupe du monde pour
s'inscrire au foot alors que la 98 des
joueurs qu'on avait joué à l'étranger
le championnat était pas fort et et
c'était à la maison c'était la maison et
c'était le brésil le brésil le
commandent la vitrine du football contre
lesquelles on voudrait on voudrait 5,4
contre lesquelles on voudrait se
confronter et le résultat était là et le
match était là et puis le suspense était
là et je pense que la 81 18 c'est quand
même je crois
deux cent quarante six mille licenciés
en plus alors là je pense pas que non je
pense pas au niveau au niveau des
licenciés on va attendre ce parce que
après après la demi finale on a déjà un
engouement et un engouement qui est plus
fort que ce que ça pouvait en 90 ans et
après je t'en parle j'ai des soucis on
est en effet après je vais bien sûr bien
sûr il n'y avait pas cet espace est
cette ferveur enfin bref c'est rien
après peut-être que je cherchais des
abus ce qu'on a pris maintenant n'ont
donc c'était une première expérience ce
qu'on va écouter justement les réactions
des yvelinois juste avant que mustapha
et pierre chevallier et régis on écoute
les événements je pense que c'est en
graignes moi ça peut ça pas avoir plus
d'impact que 2.412 suit pas forcément
plus d'impact mais je pense qu'on si on
a la coupe du monde au tout car en
france on sera très très content donc
puis ses vingt ans plus tard donc c'est
magnifique ce serait magnifique
oui je pense que là l'équipe de la
france via le 1998 et c'est pas obtenir
une équivalence entre liddes est-ce que
quatre ans dit c'était quelque chose
quand même
c'était ou 6 passes et j'en sais pas si
ça sera pareil je pense que cette année
plus de bordel parce que maintenant les
jeunes il faut plus de bordel qu'avant
enfin je sais pas j'ai appris ce qu'il
ya moins d'engouement autour de la coupe
du monde cette année que avant 2018 si
une nouvelle génération avec les jeunes
est ce qu'ils pensent ce qu'ils verront
ça comme nous l'avait joué 98
ce sera la surprise je pense que oui il
pourrait y avoir un plus sacrées
peut-être un plus grand lien entre tous
les français je pense un peu comme il ya
eu justement 98 ils seront plus forts
des halles envahi wistaff à une réaction
par rapport à ce micro trottoir convient
d'entendre bas il ya eu des choses en
contradiction les unes avec les autres
moi je vois plutôt réagir sur ce qui a
été dit
yann a raison si si mais comme c'était
encore une fois contradictoires
j'avais lu fils de mon histoire à
raconter par rapport à une autre
histoire mais c'était bien ce que les
événements 10 jan
là où il a raison c'est que en terme de
com on a mis le paquet pas ce qu'il
s'est passé vingt ans les techniques ont
évolué de marketing de communication on
a les réseaux sociaux qu'on n'avait pas
bref c'est pas un engouement pour moi
tout ça c'est un médiatisation
importante avec des moyens colossaux et
beaucoup d'argent en jeu c'est pas pour
moi de l'engouement mais finalement
c'est un peu normal toutes les coupes du
monde sont retransmises et donc toutes
les coupes du monde attire beaucoup de
monde et je prends le pari que la
prochaine attirer encore plus de monde
mais l'engouement c'est autre chose
98 c'était un vrai engouement pour une
raison simple
mon ami le dit c'est en france
l'engouement est particulier et c'est
monté crescendo parce que la coupe du
monde ce n'est pas que la finale on sera
content quand on aura pour la finale
non la coupe du monde c'est plusieurs
matches c'est les qualifs c'est des
quarts les demies et c'est donc
l'engouement il a eu lieu en france dès
le début pourquoi parce que le suspense
est d'autant plus important que ça
commence tout de suite avec l'équipe de
france on voudrait pas de la voir sortir
surtout parce que j'ai quand même les
quarts de finale
quand on sort les demi finales sauf
quand on sort loin à l'étranger il
rentre dans le bus on l'a vu en afrique
du sud
ils rentrent chez eux discrètement au
plus personne n'en parle par contre
perdre les qualifs en france sur le
territoire c'est plus compliqué donc il
y avait à la fois l'engouement
l'angoissent de pernes et puis
finalement c'est monté crescendo jusqu'à
la finale et puis un deuxième phénomène
qui à mon avis est un phénomène qu'on a
voulu plaquer
c'est cette idée de black blanc beur qui
est un truc qu'on a plaqué moi je le dis
tout le temps autour de cette table
restons dans l'objet qu'on a besoin de
traiter c'est du foot si on y plaque du
pognon on sait ce que ça donne et sont
ni plaques de la politique on sait ce
que ça donne on a plaqué le black blanc
beur et donc il ya eu tout un engouement
autour de cette france mitigé cette
france multi facettes france ethnique
multiethnique et c'est elle qui a donné
un rayonnement supplémentaires on voit
ce que ça peut donner au bout
aujourd'hui c'était c'est plutôt les 3b
c'est plus black blanc beur c'est plutôt
business business business pierre
chevalier moi je pense que c'est c'est
moins fort parce que
on n'oublie jamais sa première fois dans
certains d'être dans certains domaines
dans certains domaines même si c'est pas
la meilleure
les là en l'occurrence 98 c'était la
première et
c'était la première finale c'était le
premier titre contre le brésil à la
maison donc il y avait il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de paramètres qui est
qui il y aura d'autres ça je mettrai pas
ma main à couper les gens en termes d'
élan populaire si la france gagne ça
peut donner elle ça peut donner un 6
mois 1 an d'optimisme et d'euphorie et
ça tout le monde en a besoin et et ça ne
ça ne mange pas de pain et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment que du bon que
du positif
mais quand à comparer les 2 d2 les deux
décennies et 20 ans plus tard il ya un
lien il ya déjà un contexte et les
circonstances qui sont quand même
globalement différentes qui donneront
peut-être pas mal de pas mal
d'opérations d'opérations positive mais
qui seront un peu moins fort que le
travail 98 et je dirais pour par les
sportifs pour parler de sport je trouve
que les ce sont ces l'équipe de france
elle même et c'est des joueurs et mais
eux-mêmes qui nous rappelle à en ce
moment puisque la finale n'est pas
encore jouée qui nous rappelle en fait à
la la tempérance parce qu'ils sont
focalisés sur l'objectif
ils ont la finale de l'euro dans les
dents et en travers de la gorge
ils sont concentrés pour pour dimanche
donc c'est eux qui sont vraiment les
plus concernés et qui sont un rappel que
cette démission est enregistrée avant la
crise sont loin de licenciés voilà une
bonne n'a presque pas plu c'est qu'on
sait qu'elle aura plus parce que oui
tête de gondole avec les pelles et
griezmann
je parlais de de l'émotion suscitée
moins maintenant qu'en 98 mais par
contre plus de qom donc il ya plus
d'attractivité passage en avant plus il
ya un deuxième fait l'inscription en
septembre je pense parce que c'est
encore plus mondialisé que ça ne l'était
c'est plus marque était à briand 46e
et puis un deuxième phénomène important
c'est qu'elle de 34 ce mythe dans les
îles il ya un deuxième phénomène qui
commence peut-être plus en plus de
filles y en avait pas en 98 donc le
nombre de licenciés va augmenter au
travers d'une augmentation personnes des
filles et c'est mon seul regret parce
que chose qui était peut-être possible
en 98 qui n'est plus possible
aujourd'hui
c'est le contraire attrapant n'avait pas
de féminisme une section films depuis
quatre ans quand on veut se donner les
moyens on se bidonne et surtout ce que
je veux dire c'est que on n'a pas
suffisamment vous les filles pendant la
coupe du monde
garçons la coupe du monde fille c'est
dans un an on va voir beaucoup de mecs
sur les essais en france donc je trouve
qu'elle devrait se montrer un peu plus
nos joueuses pendant la coupe du monde
ça seront les invite pas à sanitaire
j'aurais bien aimé avoir des féminines
on en avait un train d'aller
prochainement n'hésite pas à parler si
c'est la version super le football on
passe maintenant à notre focus du jour
[Musique]
dans ce focus
retour sur les moments forts qui ont
fait vibrer les yvelinoises sur la
saison 2017-2018 le montage est signée
de l'excellent romain respini une
réaction extraordinaire une réaction de
joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on a senti
lors de l'annoncé d'un parcours de golf
fantastique et d'être le capitaine de
cette ryder cup est vraiment spécial
c'est une journée incroyable avec tous
ses enfants je suis très excité à l'idée
de vivre cette ryder cup à paris et
encore merci pour ceux qui me
soutiennent fierté un objectif de
terminer on est parti pour d'autres
objectifs ou encore le monde
[Musique]
c'est les gens qui ont gravi les
échelons de benjamins minimes cadets
juniors seniors donc la tronche âge de
18 ans je pense c'est quand même une
première au niveau national c'est le top
on ne bat bonté plus aujourd'hui est
donc pour nous c'est un honneur d'une
part et puis bah on est ravis
d'accueillir toute la france pour le
beau département des yvelines
[Musique]
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore
regarde
[Musique]
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif
pas du bras de fer de comptoir au
poignet soit bien droit qu'évoquait tôt
soit en fait je me faisais y est les
poules bien en face
que vous soyez dans l'axé médian de la
table c'est un département qui est juste
à côté de paris
barrier là et en même temps c'est la
forêt c'est la campagne ma fille a tout
pour pouvoir faire du vélo le vélo des
champions comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement était à nîmes
[Musique]
très productive
tous les bus étaient attachés pour
briser les choses des sociétés et les
partenaires les collaborateurs aussi
l'intégration
[Musique]
on est très chanceux d'avoir eu cette
fois le quart devant doublé je suis
vraiment impatient de vivre pleinement
cette expérience de mon premier roland
garros c'est génial c'est top
un quarteron forcément on s'y attendait
pas forcément mais mais c'est vraiment
un super cadeau on va essayer de se
concentrer à 100% pour en tirer le
meilleur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
victoire un peu logique et pas à pas de
surprise pour moi
chico logiquement et physiquement je
pense qu'on est un peu mieux porte pas
sur cette deuxième partie de saison donc
pas surpris disons qu'on a bien préparé
notre match depuis un moment et puis on
les aurait été super motivé voulait
absolument la gagner
[Musique]
c'est une tradition c'est l'histoire de
saint quentin en yvelines l'histoire de
cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et à que vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi de
lacaune des encours et quand on pense
qu'on y est il va y avoir les jeux
olympiques je pense que on a mis une
petite pierre à l'édifice pour que les
jeux soient ici quoi aux gens motivés à
quelques jours du départ du tour de
france pour être au départ du
championnat de france est toujours une
course spéciale donc je suis content
d'être ici quoi c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de francesco
molinari a white wolf
quand vous êtes si proche vous voulez
vraiment cette victoire
et c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir aujourd'hui net
quel est votre moment préféré sur cette
saison 2017-2018
yann championnats de france de cyclisme
à mantes la jolie
parce que
on pensait que c'était un circuit pour
les sprinteurs et on a vu un beau
vainqueur qui est sur une course qui
s'est jouée dans les 15 années km avec
une vraie course
drake aux attaques et donc anthony roux
qui gagne devant un des frères tang
turgis ce et je lui en à philippe qui
tapinent troisième donc des très beaux
champions enfin des très beaux les très
beaux sportifs qui sont qui sont sûres
sur ce podium ça n'avait pas été
organisée dans les mines depuis 50 ans
environ a c'est parce mais parce qu' on
cherche toujours à avoir des parcours
accidentés et là c'est pas parce qu'on
était sur un parcours qu'il était moins
que l'on n'a pas eu une vraie course de
mouvements beaucoup utilisé pour le
cyclisme en salle à partir de ce tacle
il faut admettre que les les premiers
événements et des malfrats ont été aussi
problématique
les championnats du monde ont très bien
fonctionné à la première année et
championnats d'europe ça a été quand
même très compliqué pour remplir le
vélodrome il ya eu des des courses qui
ont été des courses internet ont été
annulées par manque de spectateurs et
des arrestations et qui peut compliquer
donc c'est vrai que la piste a du mal à
attirer son public alors que c'est bien
dommage puisque c'est pour moi la plus
belle discipline du du cyclisme mais il
va y avoir une coupe du monde qui va
avoir lieu début octobre au vélodrome de
saint quentin et j'espère que que là on
adore d'hariri trop de l'année prochaine
voilà donc et mustapha quel est votre
moment préféré s'adonner très
sincèrement j'ai du mal à choisir il y
en a quand même plusieurs
d'où le reportage excellemment bien fait
mais du coup qui m'a noyés parce que
j'avais des des moments comme ça un peu
fort
je les retrouve quasiment diluée en a
tellement et du coup j'ai envie de
parler de mes féminine qu'ont gagné le
tournoi ont des yvelines oise ont gagné
un tournoi à auxerre les u17 avons
évidemment les images de traitement ça
va un moment
très très intenses parce qu une saison
compliquée à l'occasion on l'a pas vu
mais voilà donc un coup de chapeau
encore aux filles dans le foot mais
parce que là effectivement il ya plein
de choses et le bras de fer se farcir
silence s'il ya vraiment un moment quand
même dans l'année par rapport aux
yvelines c'est quand même l'obtention
des jo avec les sites sur les yvelines
que sont le site de vélodrome au château
de versailles le golfe donc il ya ça
c'est des moments importants parce que
je sais ce que ça va nous projeter
souvent dans l'avenir plutôt que dans le
passé donc là s'est passé j'ai un petit
peu de mal à me fixer le bras de fer
sportif le brad songez-vous les
présidents de l'association sportifs en
général
j'aurais aimé être dans le rugby ou dans
le dans leur drôle parce qu'il n'ya pas
que le foot dans la vie
je sais pas on va faire bras de fer ils
n'étaient pas équipés pour certains il
ya ce match événement préféré je
pourrais une défense avait pas ça
n'était pas où on est vraiment préféré
je dirais moi les perspectives qui font
des yvelines qui met les yvelines sur la
thèse sur la scène internationale les
deux qu'on a vu au tout début du
reportage est à dire un la ryder cup qui
arrive en septembre 2018 avec le one
year to appear to go non avant
l'événement de cette année et puis et
puis
d'accord avec mustapha de l'accueil des
jo en 2024 parce que là ça sa place sa
place les sites yvelinois les sportifs
il dit noir et tous les bénévoles et
tous les tous les dirigeants sur des
perspectives absolument absolument sans
précédent sur la scène internationale
donc tracer des perspectives qui sont
fantastiques pour le développement du
sport dans les yvelines jorge aibar vous
mais moi je judo j'ai apprécié le judo
et surtout vers la générosité avec
l'accueil de gaulle et gol de letra
l'association a le rail à y lancer un
genre du brésil le brésil dans les
yvelines avec un champion du monde
un capitaine exemplaire une fête une
fête avec les dirigeants enfin les
supporters du période paris saint
germain ou qu'on dit qu'on dit violents
qui ont fait une super fête et je pense
que voilà le sens civique de football 1
qui prime
en fait je rejoins mes amis par rapport
à par rapport au site
vraiment déjà le l'idée du vélodrome
l'idée de l'idée du vélodrome et tout ce
qui
tout ce qui tous les sites connus dans
les yvelines pour la suite de nos deux
noeuds djo et tout ce qui s'en suivent
ça va être merveilleux et puis ça
comment ça on commence à avoir des
infrastructures assez intéressante pour
pouvoir accueillir des choses et ça
c'est bien une mention spéciale pour
appeler rapidement les amarres je viens
de mention spéciale pour la ville ne
fait pas souvent je viens le rapidement
plaisir intervient souvent que ce soit
le rugby que ça soit le foot que ça soit
le voilà je ne sais pas il se passe
quelque chose et probablement que le
maire y est pour beaucoup parce que
c'est important
le psg se sont fait un plaisir c'est pas
dans toutes les municipalités si c'est
le cas c'est quand même dommage que le
message est passé moustapha c'est quand
même dommage que le pays ne soit pas
installée il devait être juste le
plaisir la ceni souvient de réunion les
gens sont à la fois ci c'est quand même
bien dommage
on passe maintenant notre rubrique
débats dans notre rubrique débats nous
allons parler de deux événements
planétaires la ryder cup et les jo de
2024 les deux compétitions seront
organisées dans le département des
yvelines on en parlait juste juste avant
du 28 au 30 septembre prochain il y aura
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines des tiger
woods derory à mcilroy pour la ryder cup
ils reviendront peut-être six ans plus
tard pour participer aux jo sur le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en
2024 le département accueillera
également les meilleurs pistards
mondiaux au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
les épreuves de cyclisme entre
versailles la vallée de chevreuse
l'équitation à versailles les courses de
bmx sur l'île de loisirs et le vtt sur
la colline d'elancourt la question sur
ce thème quel est l'événement le plus
attendu par les yvelinois ryder cup
c'est rouge vert pour les jets aux joj
ogerau vous êtes une heure après après
la différence c'est que voilà la ryder
cup c'est dans deux mois diane thériault
pouvait parler ouais merci j'ai pris la
parole
la ryder cup c'est dans deux mois donc
est-ce qu'on n'attend pas un événement
qui est quand même plus proche alors que
les gigots ses 28 au 30 septembre voilà
donc donc cesser demain
en effet ça va être ça va être attendre
24 deux mois parce que dans deux mois il
n'y aurait que du golfe mais c'est quand
même quelque chose qui va être énorme et
ça va peut-être donner un avant-goût un
avant goût de ce qu'on va dessous de ce
qu'on va vivre pendant les pendants
léger surtout qui va y rentres tu as un
pass à nantes à une invit et non tel
mais il ya quand même ce sont des
personnes qui ont raciste de compétition
pendant du monde entier par jour du
monde et quelques saint quentinois
également quelques-uns mais on va les
comptes et pierre chevalier d'accord
avec mustapha c'est un golfeur brouille
qui vous le dit évidemment évidemment le
l'exposition pour le golf français le
golf en tant que enfin la france en tant
que destination golfique pour salah
rider que c'est fantastique c'est
effectivement dans deux mois et puis ça
va passer très vite parce que c'est les
trois jours de compétition c'est sans
commune mesure avec ce que les jo vont
apporter parce que déjà c'est toute
discipline c'est l'ensemble l'ensemble
du monde sportif amateur et
professionnel qui va qui va s'y
intéresser c'est sur plusieurs sites
dans les yvelines c'est sur plusieurs
sites en france donc il n'y a pas
d'élément de comparaison entre les deux
mais de toute façon ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que c'est très beau c'est
très bon pour le département notamment
notamment aux événements expositions au
delà des perspectives dont on parle dont
on parlait tout à l'heure c'est que
c'est qu'on a on a devant nous on a six
ans ils ont de gros événement sportif et
de préparation et de monter en puissance
je pense qu'après 2024 faudra pas
s'attendre à voir d'autres beaucoup
d'autres événements nom de quoi on aura
bien profité
georges denys chapeau déjà chez chapeau
à la communauté d'agglomération ne
pouvait pas d'avoir cette politique
sportive qui est assez développée on en
accueille beaucoup d'événements et la
rideuse que la ryder cup
c'est les golfeurs et c'est magnifique
de l'accueillir maintenant quand on voit
un événement comme les jo où toutes les
poules et toutes les disciplines sont
réunis c'est incomparable mais très
heureux de pouvoir aller 750 millions de
personnes qui vont en garder la règle
est très heureux très heureux de est
très fière d'accueillir la ryder cup les
caisses et quelle chance si troisième
événement le plus médiatisé quelle
chance et quel champ sportif et après
les géniaux ces essais 5 milliard il a
tous les cas les permissions l'ensemble
de l'action non mais quelle chance pour
notre département le premier événement
c'est quand même le tour de france parce
que plein de france et tous les ans
alors que tous les événements de vous ne
parlez c'est tous les quatre ans mais le
tour de france c'est par comporte moins
de téléspectateurs que cette addition de
l'aréna bord des pistes site additionne
tous les quatre ans et qu'un événement
qui une fois tous les quatre ans je les
eaux du tour de france s'est fait plus
de plus de spectateurs sega également
par les yvelines
vois-tu juillet missionné tous les
téléspecteurs téléspectateurs qui
regardent tous les matchs de foot et
tous les spectateurs sur les terrains on
les additionne les uns et les autres
je pense que le full devrait passer de
29 millions soit la cause en serait mise
à part encore une fois le le golf 750
millions sur la planète à la télé moi 60
milles par jour à 50 en 10 20 50 jours
de compétition et 40000 sur les jours
d'entraînements sauf que ces soixante
mille
je veux bien qu'on fasse un
entre guillemets qu'on fasse un un
descriptif des gens qui vont y être je
vous le dis franchement pas hier soir
aussi
- je suis persuadé que j'en ai beaucoup
donc je ne dis pas que c'est pas mon au
contraire mais en terme de visibilité
pour l'arc à skis oui en terme de
communication pour les yvelines oui
retombées économiques
oui autorise oui bref c'est super
positif 6 m par les supporters mais mais
je dis que ça arrive quand même quelques
quelque chose qu'on va regarder de loin
et tout mais c'est pas grave parce qu'on
n'avait pas une association c'est pour
ça moustapha là il va falloir vulgariser
ce sport jusqu'à nos jours
s'arrêter avant la vulgarité d'autres
sports c'est la merci mais non je les
avais 20 secondes
pas de plus sur les gitans les gros
intérêts c'est vrai que la course sur
route qui va traverser le département va
être un point qui sera quand même
important où n'importe qui pourra y
accéder puisque ce sera gratuit sont
faites avec gratuit pourrait venir voir
et voir accorder croire passer devant
donc ça sera fortement sain pour tout le
monde on termine ce dernier numéro de
l'année par à un best-of on le regarde
et on débrief tout ça juste après et
quand vous sentez vous en ce début de
coupe du monde
eh ben j'ai hâte quatre ans qu'on
l'attend deux ans qu'on attend de
revivre et avec l'équipe de france
[Musique]
coutu bas
hmmm je suis le premier tacle de la cour
[Musique]
jean on dirait un mix entre une chouette
et jean pierre coffe est alors la
marmotte elle met le chocolat dans le
papier d'alu
mais bien sûr de son patineur c'est le
nombre de patinoires qui à montréal
voilà qui est juste il n'y a pas besoin
de rêve d'aller plus loin dans la
réflexion raté de rigoler nous avons
aussi son très bon juste avant c'est
pour ça que je me surprends 387 380 vous
avez été un peu timorés mitigé dans
votre décision gens pourquoi
non je peux dire non je peux et et tu
vois j'aurais juste la couleur j'ai des
problèmes avec la couleur suis daltonien
ça vous fait rêver
ah oui ça me ferait déjà au corps ou une
tombe à genoux dans ça permet également
de tomber malade par exemple c'est vrai
[Musique]
d'ailleurs j'ai commencé par un régime
et deux régiments à la fois parce
qu'avec un seul j'avais passé à manger
il en faut il faut se satisfaire d'une
nécessaire
ça m'a vraiment autorisé de sortir ce
soir je suis là parce que la lumière
soit je suis rentré qu'est-ce que vous
êtes venu chercher ici se soient tus
d'abord de l'association est
un peu glaçons parce que le verre ils se
réchauffent it 17 ans on sait tous que
c'est l'adolescence c'est que le bold
faut taper dans la baballe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vos bateaux pas d'expérience il a pas
sauvés d'enfants amateurs de sashimi de
soupe miso cet amoureux du japon va
malheureusement nous quitter dans
quelques semaines pour partir enseigner
le sport au pays du soleil levant
mais il est encore avec nous aujourd'hui
pour cette émission donc pas de sushi le
professeur fred anderson est avec nous
le dira sorti des chantiers dont neuf
vraie tache v
[Musique]
jeudi 6
sur les rives de la mer
que prend fin notre communauté
une règle sur les amis merci michel
s'est dit moment et puis d'ailleurs où
on se dit il faut pas rater une parce
que là il peut y avoir toujours une une
boulette
pas de bol est attendu à votre passage
non non pas du tout parce que je me suis
toujours très sérieux quand quand
intervient bien sûr fort et clair je
m'en fiche j'ai toujours des églises
d'informations très précises et aussi à
côté de vous tout à fait donc donc non
moi je m'attendais je m'attendais pas à
passer à passer donc best-of bombe à
québec montréal montréal simplement mort
et à 200 patinoire c'est le nombre de
patineurs qui vit en france bleu sur
tout le territoire c'est ridicule dire
vous révisez je vais moi je vis je les
regarde et on dira toute la saison parce
que vous êtes notre monsieur grands
événements d'ailleurs vous êtes là
aujourd'hui pour l'émission effectué de
bonnes vacances aux téléspectateurs
profitez-en pour vous reposer et
préparer la saison prochaine parce que
ça se prépare
aussi pendant les vacances gentille ont
également montré pareil d'opérations
fait partie des préparations à vous
préparer dès à présent sept ans prochain
la fin du coup pour le l'émission en
passant par les sports ah bah vous
reviendrez pas cela en vous rapatriez là
avec avec rmc
mais bravo à l'équipe parce que vous
ayez un sacré boulot là sacré boulot
c'est toi c'est moi c'est également le
réalisateur romain respini qu'également
menteur merci au revoir aux maristes
boulot voilà à ce moment là qu'on est
vraiment une équipe cirque là il ya un
cinq majeur il peut y avoir une équipe
de foot une équipe de volley il ya tous
les absents on pense à jean pour sa
hélène on pense à fred du hot 100 japon
loin de son attaque japon donc si nous
on fait on représente une belle équipe
sportive avec de bonnes valeurs et une
bonne solidarité un bon fair play c'est
toujours viril mais correct c'est ça qui
est bien
georges vous avez 10 secondes je vous
souhaite de bonnes vacances
avec avec la bonne la bonne humeur et et
puis je salue comment la ville de
plaisir et tous les ailes et les blogs
tous les administrés et puis allez les
bleus son ensemble la fin à 23 0 pour le
pronostic de dimanche contre la croatie
l'émission a bien sûr été enregistré
avant cette finale de coupe du monde
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve début septembre pour une
nouvelle saison va terminer par une
citation du footballeur pelé celui qui
pense que la victoire ne compte pas ne
gagnera jamais rien je voulais ce très
bel été sur tv 70
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]